will you play spin the bottle with me
sure all right everybody it's spin the
bottle Truth or Dare
Edition Ross are you here to help us
hello
hi the boy sneaking into the slumber
party you so nice to meet you Michelle F
you believe it I know well you want to
place in the bottle sure okay guess what
we have a bottle right here okay and all
of your scents here are labeled either
Truth or Dare got it you got it you you
want to go first I'm I'm scared I never
liked this game growing up really yeah
you played it growing up um yes of
course um only when I had to but I I I I
prefer the dares probably because I
don't like I don't like divulging
information oh well let's see what you
land on you're first okay I'm going
first yeah yeah all right I did like
spin the bottle true oh true perfect oh
wait no that's bad but go it's okay okay
ready tell us an embarrass story that
happened at a celebrity's house oh um
jeez I I don't go to many celebrities
house neither do
I um I did go to one celebrity's house
um and and her and her partner kept
talking about sex toys the whole time
and I got that's awkward
yes that that's one well that's not
going to happen at this slumber party
okay just not that's that came to my
mind okay I'm going to spin the bottle
very well behaved very well behaved now
I told a weird story okay you're up Drew
oh I got a dare you land on dare okay uh
call the most famous person in your
phone right
now so funny I don't know I'm not I
don't have that many do we have do we oh
I have we have your phone right here and
you guys can um leave whoever it is a
little voicemail from you and Michelle I
don't really know I Kate Hudson oh
that's
we all right should we FaceTime yes oh
my God let FaceTime her okay there you
go all right let's see if this
works the last time she is really big
the last time she was on the
show hello Kate
hson yes it's Drew and your video's off
and Michelle feifer FaceTiming you
where are you she's in her
[Applause]
car I love you I just I the Dare was to
call someone in my phone and I was like
I know one person who's the coolest who
will be so cool and fun well you guys
you caught me with my driving gloves on
these are my new driving gloves they're
nice I was looking at those you're so
cool decided no sunspots on my hands
there you go well well you will get some
in that little
circle thank you for letting us FaceTime
you we love you so much and I love you
both love you bye bye bye oh my God was
great
got will you spin the bottle one more
time I want to see if a dare comes up
Rossy we're hoping for a dare go you can
do it come
on
I also never got to kiss the D you got
it did you never get I never got to kiss
the boy I wanted to when I played this
that's why you don't like this game cuz
it reminds you of
lot okay here you go
ready we have to blindfold you oh yeah
don't worry you're safe okay I love it
it's like I we sure I'm okay yep yep yep
you have to lick whatever is
here
okay okay Drew is g to hold it
up how do I know when I'm there go for
it
[Applause]
oh do you trust us is it is it a
chicken I'm looking
it that's
disgusting is it is it a is it a food
yes
am I supposed to guess what it is
sure okay doesn't taste like
anything really does it smell like
something is it
[Applause]
broccoli it doesn't taste like
anything oh my gosh I mean I'm so sorry
that was so
[Music]
fun